three Americans held captive in North
Korea are returning home tonight because
President Trump made it happen through
smart and at times unconventional moves
Trump has brought dictator Kim jong-un
to the negotiating table and this
release was obviously a condition
precedent to any summit through the
president's political enemies I'm
telling you they will not give him any
credit this reminds me of a mission
accomplished moment let's not say
mission accomplished before it's a
coverage we're rewarding the North
Koreans with praise for releasing
hostages and certainly indicative of the
fact that Kim jong-un has taken this
summit seriously that the North Koreans
really are serious about wanting to sit
down it does not Allison mean that the
summit will be successful I would say
curb your enthusiasm because while it's
great that we're talking instead of
making threats Kim jong-un still has not
made any kind of irreversible
concessions to the United States this is
not a huge breakthrough Max Headroom yes
this actually is a really big
breakthrough oh my gosh one by one Trump
continues to fulfill his America first
style campaign promises it is beyond
obvious that this is driving his critics
in both parties totally bonkers after
Trump pulled the plug on the Iran
nuclear deal the usual naysayers reacted
predictably I'm very concerned as our
many of my colleagues given where we are
with negotiations now especially with
North Korea our allies and our
adversaries need to know that we are
reliable and I think that that's missing
right now our allies are upset for sure
at a time when I think the president's
sanity is being questioned globally it
was a campaign promise it does appeal
possibly to his base but their totality
of this president's behavior and
decisions does leave me to question why
he does anything and whether or not it's
to deflect from something else I don't
think he has the moral compass to make a
decision based on our own national
security even at this point actually the
president was talking about doing this
when stormy was still working in the
Late Show for three guys at a gentlemen
Club
near the Cleveland Airport give me a
break here's the reality the same people
who accused the Trump White House of
operating in a constant state of chaos
are themselves the ones trying to sow
chaos despite the fact that things are
getting better by almost every measure
they're trying to foist a scary new
reality on all of us one where a
renegade president is dangerous and he's
a destabilizing force at home and abroad
the current language out of the
administration the lack of a diplomatic
and serious engagement strategy in my
view has us sliding toward war by next
summer one Trump confidant likened the
President to a whistling teapot saying
that when he does not blow off steam he
can turn into a pressure cooker and
explode Trump's comments about nuclear
weapons have experts worried he could
literally inadvertently trigger a
catastrophe
Donald Trump is moving us toward World
War 3 there's no overstatement there
whatsoever well the results obviously
tell a different tale the world is
looking to America for leadership again
and this president is not afraid to lead
North and South Korea are talking peace
Trump is renegotiating things like the
NAFTA deal he's shown himself also to be
a surprisingly deaf diplomat especially
for someone who's not done politics
before his state dinner from Akron was a
smash and the way he's worked with Japan
and China to try to box Kim jong-in in
has been really impressive
now people forget about the coalition he
put together for those targeted Syrian
airstrikes and the bold steps he's taken
throughout the Middle East from his
outreach to the Saudis to moving the US
Embassy to Jerusalem I mean the truth is
we're in the midst of a time of pretty
amazing peace and prosperity that we
haven't seen since I think the 80s and
the economic Renaissance that we're
experiencing at home is due to the
policies of Donald Trump and the
optimism and opportunity they're
generating from coast to coast
his tax and regulatory cuts have
unleashed new investments and now
bonuses for blue-collar workers and the
likes of which we have not seen in
decades unemployment at a 17-year low US
manufacturing is up again this month
marking the strongest expansion since
2004 in a commerce department now
reporting that US factory orders rose in
March they've been up for seven of the
last eight months and according to a
recent CNN poll 57% of Americans feel
that good things are happening things
are going well in the United States
today the president Trump didn't get us
here of course by just rubber stamping
the policies of his predecessors thank
the good Lord instead what he does is he
continually tests the theories the
conventional wisdom of the so-called
experts and he actually demands to hear
alternatives to the same old policies of
the past and then after you heard he's
heard everybody he makes his own
decision
now John Bolton's answer to me last
night about Trump's decision-making
process to pull out of that Iran deal
was illustrative for people who don't
understand how the president considers
these things he doesn't make
spur-of-the-moment decisions he has
listened to everybody who wanted to talk
to him up to and including over the
weekend with prime minister may of Great
Britain he gave every one of them a
chance to try and fix the deal and
unfortunately they didn't come close
because the deal itself is inherently
flawed it's to his credit when the
president surprises his enemies and
keeps his allies and pretty much
everybody else on their toes
smart now are you thinking about its
thinking about this today this is one of
the great times to be an American happy
days are truly here again I think you
have to go back to the Reagan era to
find such a period of optimism across
the board so I say it's time to reject
the naysayers the pessimists and those
bitter sore losers who cannot stand the
fact that Trump was right and they were
and continue to be wrong now why should
we take it as gospel by the way that
Republicans
have to lose a significant number of
seats at this November because the
midterm curse of an incumbent president
if most of America is happy with the way
things are going why would they want to
wreck it all by giving power back to the
Democrats who want to just get into
office and then reverse Trump's
achievements that would be crazy
Republicans should be fully embracing
the Trump agenda and running on it not
running away from what's actually
working in fact a new CNN poll that just
dropped a few hours ago shows that the
Congressional generic ballot has
tightened in Republicans favor it's
moving in the Republicans direction back
in February
Democrats enjoyed a 16-point advantage
but guess what now it's just three a
statistical tie so in other words
Americans do have a firm grasp on
reality despite what the media and
others are saying so let's not allow the
malcontents of the left who peddled
their stormy chaos narratives to obscure
the only story that really matters the
millions of American lives improving by
the day thanks to the vision commitment
and policies of Donald Trump and that's
the angle